في المقابل افادت سلطاته خيرسون
الاوكرانيه بمقتل مدني واصابه سته عشر
اخرين في قصف روسيا على المقاطعه الجنوبيه
وقالت ان القوات الروسيه قصفت مناطق
ماهوله بالسكان خلال الساعات الماضيه
باكثر من ثلاثمائه قذيفه واضاف ان الفرق
المختصه اجلت 94 مدنيا من المناطق الاكثر
تعرضا للقصف في المقاطعه اتجاه مناطق اكثر
امنا
كما اعلنت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه ان
قوتها صدت خلال الساعات الماضيه 25 هجوما
روسيا باتجاهات دوناسك شرقي البلاد واكدت
التصدي لهجمات روسيه على محوري لمن
ومارينكا وباتجاه كوبيانس لاسيما غرب
مسيوبيكا في في منطقه
وقالت ان الغارات الجويه الروسيه تواصلت
على بخموتا دون ان يحدث اي تقدم بري في
تلك الاتجاهات
في هذه الاثناء اكدت قياده عمليات الجنوب
الاوكرانيه مواصله قواتها قصف المواقع
الروسيه على طول
جبهتيا الجنوبيه البلاد واضافت القياده ان
الخسائر الروسيه على محاور خرسون
وزبولوجيا خلال الساعات الماضيه اقتربت من
سريتين عسكريتين سقط جنودها بين قتيل
وجريح من جهه ثانيه قال الجيش الاوكراني
ان قوته دمرت اربعه منظومات صواريخ وخمسه
وحدات مدفعيه
ومستودعات ذخيره روسيه